sobrevivió al genocidio de los tutsis en
1994 sus dos hermanos fueron asesinados
en mujima este barrio de la capital
rundesa mataban a la gente aquí donde
estoy había cadáveres por todas partes y
después los tiraban aquí a una cuneta o
a una fosa como allá los habitantes del
barrio Todavía viven bajo la sombra de
este edificio construido por felicianoga
un empresario millonario acusado por la
justicia internacional de haber
financiado y organizado las masacres efa
afrodit vivía enfrente del edificio
escapó de las milicias genocidas utus
que masacraron a la mayoría de los
subsistes del barrio tras el genocidio
se unió a ifuca una organización de
sobrevivientes apoyados por el gobierno
se acuerda de las idas y venidas de las
milicias
ese edificio era la casa de Felicia en
kabuga donde estaba la sede del Antiguo
partido en el poder el mrnd las milicias
del barrio venían por sus armas aquí
venían del Norte
suscriban cuando les daban la orden de
salir a matar mujer
tras más de 23 años en fuga feliciaca
fuga fue detenido en Francia en 2020 se
sospecha que fue miembro del acaso un
círculo de extremista cercanos al
presidente antes de codearse con la
élite del país
felicianoga hizo fortuna en el comercio
del té y del café entre las colinas de
gicumbí su región de origen sus
plantaciones de té siguen ahí al igual
que sus antiguos empleados
cuando era niño había una tienda en
rusaki
donde él vendía después se mudó akigali
por negocios y regresó para comprar unas
plantaciones de té aquí
cuando venía a pagar los salarios todo
el mundo estaba contento
lo veían como un Salvador
encima de los cultivos de té los
vestigios de la fortuna de Feliciano
bugat todavía están en su pueblo
familiar bucarangue Esta es la casa
cabuga antes él venía aquí y venía para
hacer fiestas el representante de los
sobrevivientes del distrito
Anastasia kamisicunce tenía 20 años
cuando empezaron las masacres
cuando uno habla con las personas de
aquí dicen que conocieron a kabuga como
un inocente como un hombre bueno porque
era un empresario pero solo lo
conocieron hasta sus 30 años
lo que pasó después en quigalli y la
gente de aquí no lo saben en esa época
los habitantes
escuchaban la radio libre de las mil
Colinas que fomentaba las masacres y el
odio contra los tutsis un medio en parte
financiado por felicianogá que también
era el presidente del comité de
iniciativa de la radio
había muchos mensajes que decían que los
tutsis eran enemigos del país
y que había que matarlos muy rápido
así se convenció a muchos extremistas de
que había que matarlos a una gran
velocidad
en el Monumento al genocidio en quigalli
más de 100.000 personas pasan cada año
delante de la lista de los
inversionistas de la radio
hasta con unos 500.000 una suma muy
importante en esa época
por sus responsabilidades en el medio
extremista kabuga será juzgado por
incitación a cometer el genocidio
a unos kilómetros del monumento 4000
Víctimas de las masacres yacen en el
barrio de niansa ejide curanga
presidente de la asociación de
sobrevivientes y busca que exige el
traslado de felicianca buga para que sea
juzgado en los lugares del crimen en
Ruanda y no en Países Bajos una petición
rechazada por el tribunal kabuga era
parte de los planificadores del
genocidio eso significa que durante su
juicio puede revelar otras informaciones
que podrán ser utilizadas en otros
juicios
otros siguen libres
Francia Bélgica Países Bajos pero
también en África
más de 40 órdenes de detención
internacionales emitidas por Ruanda
contra presuntos genocidas instalados en
Francia siguen pendientes según las
autoridades holandesas por ejemplo a
este señor fulgens calle Chema todavía
lo buscan
siempre tratan de evadir a la justicia
para el gobierno ruandés el juicio de
felicianoga es urgente
gustaría que todos los organizadores
puedan comparecer algún día ante la
justicia El tiempo pasa y las personas
envejecen nos hemos enterado que algunos
organizadores murieron 10 o 15 años
después y no comparecieron ante la
justicia eso no es bueno para la
historia del país ni para las víctimas
aunque no existe un registro civil
Exacto el acusado tiene al menos 87 años
sus abogados han pedido que se detenga
el juicio debido a su estado de salud